I mean I'll tell you an example I met I
don't care if I'm gonna say this I don't
you I think this is like the only
network that I actually think hates me
yeah and it's I shouldn't say this but
where it's truTV okay okay so we're
doing a pilot yeah okay it's like five
years ago so you're you're difficult if
your movies don't make money if they
make money you're a genius
right you agree with that yeah yeah I
mean and to me it's not being difficult
people aren't difficult this is where
this is the sandbox man I have seen so
much [ __ ] go on that you will never hear
from me because it's the creative place
if people fight if they sleep together
if they that's what it is man do you
agree with that yes and there's so many
it's weird the culture shifted in the
last 15 years where instead of being in
it people are kind of spying on it
reporting on it also being in it you
know and it's it's not that's not how I
came up I believe that's not how you
came out oh no it was like you know
anyway I'm doing this pilot was called
Guinness World Records gone wild
[Laughter]
so my age so I I was actually kind of
feeling myself I was 2011 my agent got
me straight offer he got me a lot of
money to do it and if it was gonna go it
was gonna be 10 EPS and we would shoot
10 apps every six months yeah it was
total mailbox money yeah each you know
each epoch could buy like you know half
a Porsche you know and so I was do it
you know Halloween Horror Nights I was
being honored as the first horror guy
like it was just when that was starting
to blow up and I was doing it and I'm
like I did it a game show was like cuz
you know they come around
yeah I'm acting and it's like this is
before everything was everything this is
before that if you didn't do a job at
2:00 o'clock if you didn't do another
one at 3:30 or out of the business I
mean that's how it is now
yeah so I get the offer they close it
there go dude you're gonna have the run
of this they want the Guinness World
Records but they want that [ __ ] [ __ ]
crazy they want the Jamie Kennedy
[ __ ] sauce right and I'm like yes I
hear my friend here I hear him he starts
writing for me by getting jokes I go
down and then there's a production
company that are like the physical
production right then those are the guys
that like run the lights and put
everything and make sure you come in
time
it's Guinness World Records gone wild
yeah so they take the most crazy [ __ ]
and they do a thing on it not normal and
so one of them was the most bras that
you can unhook this is a rack guard yeah
yeah and this guy had like 83 in a
minute or something Wow and he looked
like he had a floppy hat he laid a beard
he almost had a staff and I said did you
learn that and the Shire and the network
thing um yeah you can't say that that
was a little you know a glass of tea so
I studio audience was laughing right
yeah we did another one how many
cockroaches you could put in I'm like
did you learn that with other types of
cockroaches you just lose the roaches
like you can't say you know my jokes but
I had some good ones and I had some
stinky ones yeah and so the whole thing
and I love the guy was that they wanted
at first dan Cortese I don't know if you
know that is he's a legend dan Cortese
was the original MTV great-looking guy
hosted sports and I say guys you know
you hired me if you don't want this just
call up dan Cortese he's right there
yeah he's in Malibu he already wants to
do it yeah as long as we shot dude we
did two days we shut down downtown
do you know Nokia that whole yeah took
the whole production over we shoot this
whole thing big we did a guy who did the
car flip he did three Lamborghinis so
you would flip over
we ate the next one flip over one and
they were like the guy was amazing like
[ __ ] that's now being done we did it was
seven years like pre viral right right
long short is I did something and the
guy was like yeah I don't know if we
could do that one yeah and the guys like
the hope that the chief producer was
like the rigger yes four times and this
was truTV literally they were doing cold
cases of like you know you know cold
case acrid they were doing like live
courtroom program yeah yeah
and I go and he said some to me and I go
I want to do it he goes well I don't
think we should think I want to do it
nothing I go well dude I'm [ __ ] doing
it and he goes well it's just not funny
I go bro you see those lights adjust
them do you see the camera work the
aperture I'll do the jokes with me and
Bernie and you worry about the craft
service no wait was that too much
[ __ ] tea the I don't care I'll sit
right yeah should let me run wild [ __ ]
to be serious yeah yeah yeah doing
cockroaches you're doing how many
pumpkins you can [ __ ] deceive here
yeah
and now whole bro yeah moment right yeah
yeah I I need my homie yeah yeah right
at that moment I could feel the energy
shift executives came over bah-bah-bah
and they were nice to me it was kind of
and I said guys it's just like a bad
cliche and I go guys you guys worry
about Mexicans 18 to 33 demo jokes yeah
and I know maybe it was too great it's a
little aggressive but I like it but let
me play about you pilot for some reason
I didn't get picked up
first first job I didn't get fired I
think I like a no fire clause yeah I
like a no trade Carmello clause so like
I got a little payout yeah and the next
thing I know it was on dan Cortese oh my
god have you ever her and I loved in
have you ever heard of the show no okay
here's the thing before truTV was
discovering all these new talents or
them but I don't care I don't know if
all these actives are there you tell me
if I went too far but bro it was like
well let's take the funeral Channel yeah
and they'll do a sitcom hire the guy
that knows what he's doing yeah yeah and
[ __ ] let's let's yeah dude when
you're on a set with David O'Russell Baz
Luhrmann Frank Oz and he's like improv
improv dude do more improv I just worked
with the directory of the day it [ __ ]
so go ahead Hey
yes go small I'm gonna say this I'm
probably making this the weirder the
porthole yeah the more notes it's like
you could be doing something for Redbox
Pakistan more [ __ ] notes and you
could yeah I'm a [ __ ] 20th Century
Fox movie
go ahead that's you you just nailed it
and that's when I went wow I might have
to take a [ __ ] lame timeout oh yeah
little hiatus cuz I'm like dude what are
you what's this sometimes I get a note
and I don't I don't even what the [ __ ]
they're talking about so I'll just do it
the way I was doing it mm-hmm and then I
go that's it okay
you mean they did it every time Yeah
right they just here's what it is they
want to exude they want to justify their
job dude and they want to exude you know
mean their thing right that I have power
and I have a thing to say so they say it
you know and it's like but no you're
[ __ ] lame is that bad to say honest
to god I would never ever tell Roger
Federer how to [ __ ] hear back
yeah yeah but it's like if I but somehow
telling comedians or writers it's just
like there's no barrier to entry if it's
if it's arrogant okay if it's an Aaron
Sorkin proverb [ __ ] right and he goes I
want it the way it's written you know
that his writing is at the top level of
course he's known for you're gonna do
that yes well you're get hired if you're
not gonna do words David Mamet and
everything's goes in or or if it's a
procedural where you have to say this
line because it connects to another
scene right yeah yeah that mm-hmm
but when you're doing comedy dude but
couldn't let me ask you this then
because year and a half ago I was and I
know this your channel is popular now
yeah I don't think they'll look at me
but I still don't really besides the
Carbonaro effect
and Adam ruins everything yeah which I
do watch those I like those I don't know
a lot of the other shows so I don't know
but they are making a big stink so yeah
I know yeah yeah
[Music]